The midpoint between 3,15 and 10, negative 2 is the point 6.5, 6.5. Of course,
you could write this as a fraction instead of a decimal too, if you wanted to.
But how do we get that? Well, in order to get halfway from here to here, we know
that we need to go half as far both horizontally and vertically. Let's once
again start with the horizontal distance, or the distance in x. Our x
coordinates or our given points are 3 and 10. So halfway between 3 and 10 is
what? Well, the distance from 3 to 10 is just 10 minus 3. So that means that
halfway between 10 and 3 is just 10 minus 3 over 2. And simplifying that gives
us 7 halfs, or 3 and a half. This, however, is not our coordinate. This is just
the distance that we need to move from one point toward the other point. So to
figure out our actual coordinate, we need to start at one of our points and walk
toward the other point this far. So our x coordinate is just equal to 3 plus 7
halves, which is just 13 over 2, or 6.5. Let's do the same thing for the y
coordinate. Our y coordinates are 15 and negative 2. If we use our handy dandy
grid here to count how far this distance actually is, we can see that it is 2,
4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16, plus 1 more to be even with this point, 17. So we each
move 17 boxes vertically to get from negative 2 to 15. Half of that is just 17
over 2 or 8 and a half. But again, this is not actually our Y coordinate. This
is just the distance vertically between these 2 points. To find the coordinate,
we need to start at one of these points, and then move this vertical distance
toward the other. So if we start at 15, we need to move down 8 and a half, since
negative 2 is below 15. And this gives us a y coordinate of 13 over 2. Let's
graph this point just as a sanity check. 6 point 5 6 point 5 should be right
about here. And if we draw a line from our first point to our second point, we
see that this point does in fact lie on the line, and looks half way between
them.